good evening
christmas is a time for family for
friends and for neighbors
to be with them yes
but also to care for them and protect
them
this christmas once again we're at a
critical moment in our fight against
covid
the new variant omicron is spreading
fast and the argument that we don't know
enough about it doesn't stack up
we may not be certain how dangerous it
is
but we do know that lives are at risk
and again our nhs is at risk of being
overwhelmed
if that happens
more people will die
so we must do everything we can to
protect the nhs
the scientists are clear our best
defense is the booster jab
the vaccine is safe and effective it
protects us and those around us
that's why labour supports the
government's plan to get every adult
boosted by the end of the month
and personally i want to urge every one
of you to book an appointment or go to a
walk-in center
as soon as you can
we must also use this christmas break to
vaccinate children over 12
and stop the spread in schools
if you haven't had your first or second
jab
now is the time to come forward
it matters more than ever
and let's face it a booster for every
adult before the end of the month
is a big challenge
which is why we argued that the
government should have stepped up
sooner but time and time again
the british people have risen to the
challenge
so let's pull together now
and do the right thing once more
at times like this we must all put the
national interest first
and play by the rules
of course i understand that sticking to
the rules can be inconvenient
but stick to the rules we must
it will be easy to let the festivities
we've all been looking forward to
divert us from our national duty
getting jabbed
wearing masks
and working from home if we can
really will help prevent infections
and help prevent the nhs being
overwhelmed
i want to take this opportunity to thank
all of you for everything you've done so
far
and everything you will do in the coming
weeks
your efforts
will save lives
i also want to thank our brilliant nhs
workers for their dedication
their skill
and their sheer hard work
we're so fortunate in this country to
have the nhs
we must do everything we can
collectively
to preserve and protect it
we spent the early months of the
pandemic applauding the brilliant
efforts of the nhs
now our shared national duty
is to stand shoulder to shoulder with
our nhs heroes
and the committed volunteers supporting
them
the labour party that i lead will always
act
in britain's best interests
the labour party that i lead will always
do everything within its power to
protect the nhs
the nhs that's done so much good
since labour founded it
almost 75 years ago
as leader of her majesty's opposition
it is my solemn duty
to challenge the government where
necessary
the health safety and security of our
nation and its people
must always be the first priority
that's why we will always support
measures designed to protect public
health
that includes the measures in plan b
we are a patriotic party
and it's our patriotic duty to vote for
these measures
to ensure that they go through
in doing so
we are supporting the nhs
and supporting our country
but rest assured i will still hold the
government to account in the coming
weeks
that is also
in the national interest
meanwhile i'm asking all of you
to do your bit too
at this time we need leadership
leadership that the country can trust
it's a big national effort
and we all have our part to play
get britain boosted
protect the nhs
and save lives
and from my family to yours
i wish you a very happy christmas
celebra leader sakir stamo responding to
the prime minister boris johnson's
address to the nation last night about
accelerating the booster program and our
political editor beth rigby is here with
me we were discussing what the labour
leader might say before he said it and
uh beth pretty much as expected not
playing party politics as uh sakir said
they're talking as he said in the
national
interest but critical of the lack of
leadership i mean not overtly
talking politics but that was extremely
political look on the policy
uh he urged everyone to book an
appointment so urging the public to get
those boosters he called on the
government to use the christmas break to
vaccinate children over 12. there hasn't
been huge take-up
for over 12 so calling for a bigger push
on that to try and get more secondary
school children vaccinated
and then he criticized the government
for not stepping up sooner on the
rollout when it came to the politics of
it he didn't out rightly criticize
conservative mps for for rebelling he
didn't openly criticize the prime
minister but there was lots of criticism
in there when he made the point that the
labour party he led acted in britain's
best interest he said that he will
always support measures designed to
protect public health he said we are a
patriotic party and it's our patriotic
duty to vote for these measures to
ensure they go through and if that isn't
a man trying to prove to the public that
he is a government in waiting i don't
know what it is and quite a prime
ministerial tony must be said
addressing the british people directly
urging them as we say there to get
boosted and even the the way that the
room was was dressed a direct echo of
how we saw boris johnson last night a
direct echo he had uh the union jack he
had a picture of his family behind
it was a very different look to some of
those legal textbooks that in the past
he's had look there is a
sort of image being built here
you know as well in some of those
reports internal reports about why did
labour lose the last election a lack of
patriotism seen by the public towards
the labour party and leadership at the
time was a big factor in that and
kirsten were really trying to to build
back that impression with the public i
thought also he did criticize boris
johnson but he did it in quite a subtle
way when he said at this time we need
leadership leadership that the country
can trust he also said at times like
this we must all put the national
interest first and play by the rules
leaning into two things that he keeps
talking about that this is a prime
minister uh that is not trustworthy and
that is not playing by the rules and is
breaking promises so that message in
that he pumps out
prime minister's question he's put that
into this address but he definitely
sought to rise above avert party
politics there and say well you had that
guy yesterday giving you a national
address and here's my attempt and do you
like the look of me i mean that was
definitely what he was trying to do in
that statement tonight